Why can't you just
leave my daddy alone?
Oh, Cassie, this must all
seem like a bunch of confusing
grown-up stuff to you, huh?
Your school has rules, right?
Like, you can't
draw on the walls.
Well, your daddy went to
Germany and drew on the walls
with Captain America.
And that was a
violation of Article 16,
Paragraph 3 of the
Sokovia Accords.
Cassie, let the man get by.
But Daddy's super sick.
I'll see about that.
He says he doesn't want
anyone else to get sick.
Well, I'll take
my chances, sweetie.
He barfed, like a lot.
Young lady, I'm
a federal agent.
I've seen worse
things than vomit.
Like a lot, a lot?
- Yes!
- Forget it.
Move aside!
Sir?
Can you knock?
Sorry, sir.
But I just got a lead.
Ooh, I love leads.
Wow, you're really
great with kids.
Thanks.
I'm also a youth pastor.
How'd you do it, Scott?
Do what?
The card trick.
Seriously?
Did you want to grab dinner?
I mean, 'cause I'm free.
[MUSIC PLAYING]